anyone with information to come forward
after a man was shot and killed in the
east valley
sasha loftis joining us live near
charleston and peco sasha with the very
latest
denise and brian this scene wrapped up a
little while ago but police
are still trying to piece together
exactly what happened here what led up
to this shooting
now it all happened between these two
buildings here in that alleyway
earlier tonight it all started around 6
30. police say the victim who's
described as a white man in his early
30's
was talking to a woman behind that
building there in between those two
when police say the suspect approached
and shot at them multiple times
that suspect then ran off the man who
was shot was taken to umc where he later
died
detectives are still searching for the
suspect here and they're asking the
public for help
anytime something like this would happen
i just urge people to stay inside
call the police report the incident and
just
be a good witness and that's why i urge
any of your viewers to please reach out
to crime stoppers
and help us solve this case
police aren't sure if the victim and the
suspect knew each other or exactly what
led up to this situation
officers say the suspect did leave here
though on foot
he is described as a black or hispanic
man no other details available
at this time but if you have any
information know what led up to this
situation you are asked to call
metro homicide or crime stoppers you can
remain anonymous with any tip there
that number you see on your screen
702-385-5555
reporting live in the east valley
tonight sasha loftis 8 news now